it was your brother had heard an
interesting story can you share that
story with us isa yeah so uh we met him
lou shropshire uh just three years ago
and so when we went into um his uh when
we were going there samuel told us that
he has six guns under his bed waiting
for muslims to come over and so
we went there and we spoke to him about
different topics but we didn't get to
speak to him too much about islam it was
indirect tawa and so it was time for
prayer and so he said yeah it is time
for prayer we said yes we can pray later
but he said no you can go ahead right
now i would like to take a video of it
so as we went inside to make
we saw a poster and it said to kill a
muslim and to take him directly to hell
you put um what's it called the bullet
in pig grease and so we were like wow
we're very surprised um but then we made
we started praying and when we pray we
say allahu akbar allahu akbar and so is
that is that like a war cry no that's
what people think
sadly
god is great that's it
is that kind of like a hallelujah yeah
it is yeah it is i mean alhamdulillah
god is great god is wonderful hallelujah
no hallelujah
okay so you were saying like uh yes
equivalent to hallelujah god is the
greatest correct and then what happened
and so um his neighbor heard us and so
he said hey lou i hear some muslims
saying allahu akbar would you like me to
come with my shotgun and then lu
shropshire said not yet i will let you
know
that there is still a possibility and
then he told us to sleep over his house
i was like maybe he didn't catch us the
first time while praying now he wants to
catch us while sleeping and so we slept
we woke up alhamdulillah we were about
to leave but he started us
still asking us some questions and then
two questions he asked us and he said
how can i come to islam how can i be a
muslim and so a person that hated
completely islam now wanted to learn how
to become a muslim and so we told him
the six pillars of faith we told him
i bear witness that there is no god
except allah and prophet muhammad is a
messenger and so he said i believe in
allah and i believe in the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him and he said
he will learn more in the future but the
second thing that affected me he said
you know it's not my fault that i don't
know about islam it's your fault that
you never told me about islam or any
muslim told me about islam he lived for
more than 80 years and nobody told him
about islam but alhamdulillah we reached
out to him before his death two years
before his death and a couple of months
ago we went to his memorial and saw him
uh there now there are can you imagine
how many people are out there just like
that correct they have the wrong
perception about islam much of it
through the media and much of it
sometimes to just fringe elements
not representing islam correctly and
then you have also sometimes deliberate
attempts to divide us as human beings by
certain corrupt people organizations
whoever the case because it's a big
industry now making money fueling this
division
yes this hate of islam because you'll
always be fearful of the unknown you'll
be fearful of the unknown but now this
is your brother he gets the proper
education he just spends a little bit of
time asking questions look how powerful
that was that at the end then he saw you
guys praying coincidentally like jesus
prayed with your face on the ground
that's how jesus prayed and practicing
the same way of life that jesus
practiced is nothing different
submitting your will because islam means
to submit your will to the creator that
happens in earth correct and that's what
you guys were doing to the point that
he's like how can i what did he say how
can i be a muslim and that sign he had a
sign so you imagine the kind of
distorted you know ideas that a person
had and the hatred that he had assigned
this is how you send them to uh hell put
a bullet in the pigs
greece yes
man it's bad but you know it's not his
fault and i like this it's partially our
fault now he's pointing yes and then he
came to the camera yes yes he pointed
like this and it was very scary for us
because he said you know it's not my
fault that i didn't know about islam
it's your fault that you never told me
about islam or any muslim never told him
about islam so for the 80 years that he
lived no one told him about islam and
like him there's hundreds of millions of
people dying every year not knowing
anything about islam and so if we can
reach out to them many of them like
brother samuel would come into islam
what did you think after this encounter
with your brother now and all this you
know
his reaction
well you know
you think of reality reality is um
islam is reality
god is reality alhamdulillah
and
the reality is
he loves us he cares for us he has mercy
upon us
the more i learned about islam and the
more i learned about prophet muhammad
peace be upon him the more i understood
god's grace and mercy
god the most merciful the god who
distributes mercy to all who request
freely
it's a great experience
and now to be able to share that mercy
with others and to be able to share that
salvation with others who are seeking
help
so you went from one point in our